Alexandra Palace England dance legends
faithless are on tour to promote their
new remix album celebrating 20 years of
global success
for anyone working in the music industry
it's been two decades of upheaval the
digital revolution has transformed how
we all consume music but one thing has
been slow to change the business model
if someone makes a record for a major
label the label still owns the record
the only thing that's comparable to is
if you take out a mortgage to buy a
house and you pay back the bank and then
the bank owns your house but there's a
new disruptive voice in the industry
that's getting louder it's from a tech
startup called cobalt and they're using
the same digital revolution to rewrite
the rules I have never liked a bullets
I don't see why bullish we'll walk
around and make other people's lives bad
we're taking on the big boys and we've
said to people you can be the Masters of
young destiny across the world old
industries are facing disruption on an
unprecedented scale people are not
making other taxes confronted by
ever-changing technology the pressure to
adapt has never been greater it is
always survival the fittest that's
capitalism because were those threat
there's also opportunity
in the music industry it's always been
survival of the fittest
after decades of technological change
today just three major record labels own
well over half of the Western world's
music it's a ruthless business music
business it's a very tough business to
succeed in the biggest label of them all
is universal
Nick Raphael runs their UK imprint of
Capitol Records and has helped sustain
their success by investing heavily in
new talent like Grammy Award winner Sam
Smith the most important thing for a
record company is to find talent and to
find repertoire you know the A&R process
and it doesn't matter whether we are in
streaming downloading seventy-eights
cassettes vinyl or CDs it doesn't matter
what era we're in the truth is the way
Capitol Records succeeded is by signing
and having great artists and we invest
millions upon millions find the next
superstar trying to find the next
brilliant artists trying to find your
wedding song not that we trying to find
it your weddings on but ultimately the
songs that will make the soundtrack to
your lives that soundtrack may have been
created by the artists but it's the
labels who retain the rights to the
music
we make all the investment in terms of
skill set and money right and we take
the risk it's a model that some artists
have been questioning for years
including one of the biggest rock bands
on the planet Radiohead artists
contracts were so heavily weighted in
favor of the record companies it was
just hugely unfair you know and I don't
think anyone anyone in any in the red
convers anything would dispute that they
might put their head on a go where you
know what we've put lots of investment
yeah you have but you know let's talk
about you know something that's truly
fair let's just see it for what it is
you know we we didn't have a choice
we wanted to make music
the rapid rise of digital music gave
Radiohead an opportunity to challenge
the status quo
at the end of their contract with label
EMI in 2007 they released their new
album in rainbows over the Internet
themselves and they allowed fans to pay
whatever they liked there was a cover of
music week which had a figure of a penny
I think on the on the front so look a
you know what if you're in the camp of
being excited by innovation and change
then you loved it you know clearly
within the recorded music business
there's a lot of people who are not that
way and are still not that way so that
kind of change is a little bit of a
threat
Radiohead's pioneering move proved a
critical and commercial success in
rainbows earned them more digital income
than all their other albums combined and
stunt the entire industry that resonates
today you know we were like that you you
speak to a lot of you know
well-established acts they will quote
back that thing of well if radio can go
and do that then you know what a bunch
of us can - while Radiohead were
publicly challenging the music
establishment a small technology company
was busy behind the scenes developing a
system that would enable more artists
and writers traditional industry model
cobalt is the brainchild of Swedish
musician an entrepreneur Willard R
dreads the old model is on the way out
so I'm building the new music industry
structure Corbett has a big mission it's
simple but it's a big mission to take
the music industry into the digital age
weird trance Paris and trusts we wanted
to make everything transparent and open
and fair which doesn't sound like a big
thing but in the music industry that's
quite revolution Cobalts opportunity
came when music downloads started to
give way to a proliferation of streaming
sites like Deezer
and Spotify
for artists it was becoming virtually
impossible to keep track of who was
consuming their music cobalt was one
step ahead of the industry with its
technology and the appealing prospect it
offered artists of getting paid suddenly
he is a company that actually going to
tell you what you're earning help you
earn more money help you own your own
money quicker and handle those billions
of transactions from billions of
different sources and and pile them all
up make sure that the writer got paid
every little percentage of a cent they
should have been paid cobalt now
represents over 8,000 artists and
songwriters and the technology has been
embraced by some of the biggest names in
the industry including multi million
album selling band Snow Patrol not only
does cobalt system monitor every digital
download of a song
thanks elf comfortable but it's able to
collect the tiny micro payments artists
and writers get from every play on a
streaming site to dine with the Snow
Patrol record fall empires is what's the
biggest performance song do you think is
it would it be New York or I think it is
yeah we can have a look on the report
and we're definitely kept in the dark
before this is very transparent very
easy to understand they've been able to
collect money that no one else has been
able to see through their their software
and we've seen 23 percent more income on
on a song through cobalt today cobalt
has a global turnover of nearly a
quarter of a billion dollars and the
confidence to take its revolution to the
next level
the company now wants to challenge the
entire structure of the industry by
taking on the vexed issue of music
ownership four years ago Cobalt started
offering services to help artists record
and distribute their music similar to a
record company
but unlike a record company cobalt lets
the artist retain the rights to the
music they simply charge them fees for
the services the artists want them to
provide really good loads of energy I
think it's ready to go it sounds perfect
to me that whole idea of owning your own
record and getting someone to mark and
distribute it for you is the biggest
threat to traditional major record
labels we've said to people you can be
the Masters of your own destiny you
don't need to give away your rights to
earn your money in fact you'll earn more
money if you don't give away your rights
10 years ago if you were a new artist or
a new band really the first step on the
ladder was to get a record deal now
that's just an option that you don't
have to take Cobalts new model may work
for established artists such as Paul
McCartney Lionel Richie and Nick Cave
but they are yet to break a new act into
the mainstream which is one area where
the major labels have a powerful defense
their proven track record so what cold
well in my opinion offer is for artists
writers that do not need advances that
do not need development that's great for
the privileged few that can afford to do
that but actually if a new writer comes
along and needs developing and needs
time and needs money and nurture that's
not their strongest point we've signed
artists in the past didn't have one song
that we liked that was good enough to go
to market for 18 months so we spent 18
months with them writing every day
writing with different people meeting
different people getting into understand
what we thought took to make a record
and I think the record company can help
mold and develop artists
labels also provide their artists with
expertise from in-house promotional
marketing and accounting teams services
they can afford to offer thanks to their
rich back catalogs stretching over 80
years of recorded music one classic one
from our catalog these are seminal
records one calling classic that's one
of ours on Columbia it's quite pleasing
to know that those labels that I used to
watch turn around when I was a teenager
in the 80s is not something I you know
pays my salary that's quite exciting
Sony Music has one of the most lucrative
back catalogs generating over a billion
dollars in revenue every year I think
the back catalog is absolutely vital to
our business because back catalogue
creates the flow of cash that allows us
to invest in new talents that kind of
equity in the brand is something that
allows us to then fund our acquisition
of new talent so catalog is absolutely
vital always has been and I suspect
always will be it's a virtuous circle
the funds generated by back catalogs
help to build success for new artists
whose back cutter locks the label will
then go on to own but there's a growing
number of new artists who don't seem to
need the record labels to become a star
I love you so guys Jacobs my entry for
the Perez Hilton can you sing cover
competition jacob whitesides was just 13
years old when he started posting videos
of himself singing on youtube now just
18 he's completed two American tours and
his first sellout tour of Europe
Jacob was able to build his fan base
himself through social media
he now has more Twitter followers than
Madonna and Bruce Springsteen combined I
have 1.8 million on Twitter 1.5 million
on Facebook 1.2 million on Instagram the
fans have just really their more
powerful and most in any label that you
can or any
they post my music they go and find
other people that are searching for new
music and send them on music people pay
like hundreds of thousands of dollars to
get this kind of promotion you know a
lot of artists don't need deals you know
if they can establish a solid touring
foundation they can they can make money
they can pay their bills those fans
Artie captured they create that freedom
and I feel like a lot of artists lose
that when they jump straight to the
major label
Jacob is just the latest in a new
generation of emerging artists who grew
up inside the digital revolution and
seemed increasingly skeptical of the
sales pitch from the traditional labels
who predated it at Alexandra Palace in
North London some other emerging artists
are preparing for their biggest ever gig
supporting faithless in front of
thousands how long have we got to a
person so normally about at exactly an
hour before I start kind of doing this
bit yeah which would normally be now so
and it does this for a long time not see
wrong look at the stamina that you stage
until the ribbon breaks is one of
Cobalts latest signings rather than
dreaming of starry-eyed celebrity the
band was drawn to the tech companies
pragmatic approach someone like Col Volt
is amazing for like a career based
project rather than a flash in the pan
the idea of kind of making it it is a
very different idea to the idea of
having a career it's not about thinking
of this moment you think you're gonna
have where everything changes and you've
hit some kind of plateau or suppose I
think I think it's just nice to to be
able to make music full-time you've made
it
as more bands choose to control their
own careers this poses a challenge the
major labels can't afford to ignore I
think we've had to recognize that to get
to progress and to get to continue to
have a place in there in the echo system
of music going forward and to be able to
continue doing what we do we've needed
to look take a good long hard look at
ourselves and kind of evolve they're now
investing in not just the artists but
also the platforms on which their music
is played some sources claim that
together they own nearly 20% of
streaming subscription service Spotify a
stake that's estimated to be worth at
least one and a half billion dollars and
they've also acknowledged that they no
longer hold all the cards when dealing
with talent part of what's happened is
we've become much more service-oriented
in our mentality thinking a lot more
about what specific set of needs does
this particular artist require to
commercialize their art
that can be the verisimilitude I mean
it's pretty it's pretty there I say a
little sexy Jacob oh that's gonna go
after years of fierce independence in
2015
social media star jacob whitesides
signed a record deal with BMG under
terms unthinkable even a few years ago
it's Jacob not the label who retains all
rights to his music I don't my music I
decided when I wouldn't go on tour
there's really like no I have a 100%
creative control which was just the one
thing that I wanted and that's not a
popular thing most deals is not like
alright you decide what you want to do
if I just went in with my talent alone
then they would have been able to to
craft it the deal however they wanted to
but they saw the leverage I had and they
knew that I didn't necessarily need them
that it was more of a partner
partnership type thing so I feel like
that was the most and the most important
thing is just going in with something
instead of nothing
we're in an age where people who nothing
to do music can build up a profile and a
business based on their opinions or
their looks on social media I don't see
its disruption it's an opportunity and I
love that opportunity and I hope I get
to share an opportunity for the rest of
my working days it's this adaptability
that's kept the labels on top a skill
they need now more than ever the major
labels thought that they were more
important than the artists and they
never were and now as the artists leave
they're clearly seeing that in the world
of music nothing is bigger than the
music itself
you